welcome everybody to Sunday morning
science John Perry here today I'm very
excited about my guests I have dr.
Donald Moss who's gonna be here with us
and before I introduce him and show him
introduce him to you I want to talk a
little bit about today's topic it's how
to distinguish between real medicine and
snake oil so fake medicine that someone
might be selling you either because
they're just trying to make a profit off
of you and take advantage of you or
because there's someone genuinely thinks
that there's an actual treatment for a
disease that mainstream medicine is not
yet clued into almost all of us at some
points in our lives we will be diagnosed
you know if you live long enough you'll
be diagnosed with some sort of a
disorder or disease that there's no good
treatment for so maybe maybe there's no
treatment for it at all or maybe there
is a treatment but the treatment is
absolutely horrible and if if not you
someone that you love you know in
especially this is this is especially
traumatic if it's your kid you know and
when we get in these situations we allow
a lot of times we become desperate
there's this beautiful quote by a
comedian Tim Minchin he says do you know
what they call alternative medicine
that's been proved to work
it's called medicine and that statement
is it's well it's pretty hilarious when
you're not sick and or when you're sick
and there is an unavailable treatment
for whatever it is that you have but
when you're in this desperate situation
where modern medicine doesn't have have
an option for you things like that the
kind of the punchiness and the comedy
behind those statements it fades away
pretty quickly and all throughout
history this has been a problem I've
been reading this book on the the Black
Plague called the Black Death and you've
if you've been watching this show
regularly you've you've heard me talk a
lot about the Black Plague and I just
wanted to read to you here what people
were doing during the desperate
times of the plague because we really we
had no clue for hundreds of years we had
no clue how to treat this horrible
disease it was just wiping out
populations and so all sorts of
different treatments and remedies were
invented and there's a whole chapter
just on plague remedies here and there
are dozens of just crazy things that
people were doing but I want to read to
you a couple of the craziest this is
what the doctors were doing before they
go out in the morning to go treat their
patients they would take their own urine
and this is actually the night before
they would take their own urine put it
in a glazed pot and boil it until it
evaporated to a salt after this they
take a good knifepoint full of the salts
on a piece of bread which has been
dipped in sweet oil and eat it early in
the morning on an empty stomach
they then drink a good drought of herb
wine and wind in contact with their
patients they chew a bit of plague wort
so I don't know if he's ever peed on a
fire but boiling urine in your house
would be absolutely horrible
and they were doing it every day
drinking your insult or eating your
insults and then another really
interesting one so that first one is
like a home remedy so obviously no one's
trying to make him make money off of
that there's no snake oil salesman
involved there this is just a treatment
that people really thought worked and so
they were doing it medical professionals
we're doing this and then you've got
some some things you know clever
marketers were were taking advantage of
this situation and we have here this is
when Henry the second was was trying to
expand his empire so his army they got
sick with the plague it says the plague
broke out in his army and the leaders as
well as the sick attendants we're said
to have protected themselves by wearing
hollowed-out hazelnuts filled with live
mercury around their necks and so you
have all sorts of you know jewelry
makers and you know miners who were
finding different jewels and emeralds
and they would claim that that these
substances you know in this case mercury
but also there's a lot of examples of
different jewelry and stuff that people
would use and they would say that this
will protect you from the plague and so
you have just this insane amount of
confusion on top of that you have people
exploiting those who are frightened to
make a living and my guest today dr.
Donald Moss let me introduce you to him
hello Donald hello nice to be here
Don Moss he has spent his career or the
healthy chunk of his career trying to
figure out which medicines actually work
which things you know as Tim Minchin
says here what do you call alternative
medicine that works that's been proved
to work you call it medicine and Donald
Moss is is one of these people who
actually does the research to figure out
if something is medicine or not and so
I'm very happy to have you on on the
show today thank you I'm very much
looking forward to this this is very
interesting things yeah I I think you
know we just read some of these crazy
remedies that have been used in the past
that were unproven and ended up being
proven not to work so putting mercury
around your neck eating your own urine
but there's actually weirder things that
have been proven to work
so there's actually I was I was just
going over some some things this week
there's several medicines that come from
snake venom there's yes there's a
medicine right now in trial that come
it's a painkiller that comes from tick
saliva penicillin comes from mold and so
on and then you have found some really
interesting things in your work we were
just talking about this before before
the show you want to tell us about your
your research with Tourette's syndrome
well yes and I want to emphasize that a
lot of the things that we do have in
modern medicine have come from well of
course have come from natural products
because that's basically all people had
to start with and I want to go back to
some of the oldest Western literature I
want to go
back to Homer's Odyssey and as our
viewers may know Odysseus was one of the
heroes of the Trojan War and this was
about 800 BC and on the way home after
the Trojan War
Odysseus and his crew were captured by a
sorceress named Searcy on an island and
they just got detoured on the way home
and Searcy served his crew apposite they
called it a posit and his crew became
incapacitated hallucinate 'add forgot
their homeland and they came under the
power of Searcy and Odysseus was back on
the ship and when the messenger came and
told him about the crew being captured
by Searcy Odysseus started up the hill
to Searcy's lair to rescue his crew and
on the way up the hill through the
forest he was interrupted by a messenger
of the gods
a guy named Hermes a messenger the God
God's appeared before him and gave him a
black twisted root and he told him that
it came from a flower of the head of
white blossom and a girl in the dark of
the forest and to take it home and make
tea and drink it before he went in so he
did that and he went up there and Searcy
gave him this her posset intending to
take control of gaseous and Odysseus was
completely immune to it Odysseus fought
with Searcy depending on which version
of the story you like to hear
anyway he freed his crew and then
continued on his way home well the
importance of this is that Searcy's
posset contained the atropine and
scopolamine which are belladonna
alkaloids that
Tunisia and hallucinations yeah and
they're in modern-day jimsonweed that
people use for abuse to get high and
that kind of thing but what Odysseus had
as a protection against that was what we
now call homers Molly it contained a
compound called galanthamine and
galantamine reverses the effect of
scopolamine and atropine and galantamine
today is used as a treatment for
Alzheimer's disease it's a
cholinesterase inhibitor for Alzheimer's
disease but and I work on Alzheimer's
disease also yeah my interests in
alternative medicines like the
cannabinoids came from an original
research that was done by a guy named
David Janowski David Janowski had the
hypothesis that the high that you get
out of marijuana remember this is in the
1980s so as before we understood that
cannabinoids have their own
neurotransmitters and their own
receptors in the brain yeah
David Janowski thought that it was
producing its effect by interfering with
acetylcholine in the brain and so he
thought well if if you get high by
blocking the effect of acetylcholine in
the brain with marijuana then I can
correct the marijuana high by giving you
a drug that enhances acetylcholine
it was a little study of mechanism if
you believe that it blocks something in
the brain and give a drug that's known
to reverse it and so he was at
Vanderbilt University at the time and he
talked a couple of graduate students in
pharmacology to go out and get really
stoned and then come in to the Student
Health Center to be treated for
marijuana intoxication yeah
and they did and they came in and when
they were in there they were laughing
and carrying on and by the way this is
all published in the British Journal of
pharmacology in about I don't know 1975
yeah but anyway he then hooked up the
students with an IV and gave them a drug
called physostigmine and physostigmine
as a cholinesterase inhibitor and so it
stops the breakdown of acetylcholine and
what it does is it amplifies
acetylcholine it makes an increase in
concentration quickly and if marijuana
is producing its high by blocking
acetylcholine this should reverse it
right but it turned out it did reverse
it terribly dramatically the students
went from laughing and carrying on
talking and everything - sobbing really
saying you didn't know if they didn't
know that the drug was producing this
depression they didn't know how they
would keep from killing themselves and
that kind of thing and so David Janowski
it took him about 30 minutes and I have
joked with him that's probably the
amount of time that it took him to go
call his attorney and ask what he needed
to do about the situation because it was
not an approved trouble oh yeah yeah it
was just an informal thing but then he
went back and he gave him the atropine
this is the drug that I was telling you
that Searcy had in her possib yeah that
would reverse the effect of the
physostigmine right
and he gave him atropine and they
recovered and they were then back to
normal the whole thing took a couple of
hours yeah and so I had talked to David
Janowski about this and I was wondering
how that could work maybe this was a new
way to understand how the brain controls
mood because none of the drugs that we
have today act on acetylcholine none of
the approved drugs act on acetylcholine
they work on
dopamine norepinephrine and serotonin
you talking about the approved drugs for
like depression and so on that's right
improved drugs for depression and what's
interesting about them is that you have
to take them two or three weeks before
they begin to have their therapeutic
effect yeah and I was thinking boy this
is really close to the mechanism in the
brain because the effect happened in a
matter of 30 minutes right you know it
was a dramatic effect and so that
started me off on studying how marijuana
worked in the brain I wanted to
understand that and that led me down a
long path I never did understand I never
did discover how marijuana affects mood
but along the way I did an experiment
where I was giving physostigmine and THC
I got the pure THC from the National
Institute on Drug Abuse and did this in
rats and I was looking for something
where marijuana would do one thing and
then you give them physostigmine it
whenever it would reverse it and I was
giving rats THC and I guess they enjoyed
the experiment pretty well I don't know
you can't tell anyway I was then given
I'm Faisal stigman to see if it would
reverse the effect of marijuana and what
we were doing in rats is THC does have
an analgesic effect it does reduce the
perception of pain and so we had rats
that were stoned on THC and then we
would give them a little test we would
induce some pain in their paw yeah
measure how much they lick their paw and
that kind of thing whether they could
walk on it and then we gave them
physostigmine and I had a student
running this experiment and a guy named
Richard Johnson and one day Richard
Johnson came in to my office and he said
you better come and look at these rats
you better come and look at this
experiment mm-hmm I went in there and
looked at these rats and they were just
frozen they were little statues they did
not move
and remember they had a painful stimulus
on their paw and they weren't doing
anything and so I took the rat and I
turned it over on its back and the rat
would write itself which meant that they
were aware they weren't has blacked out
and they'd frozen and that was totally
unexpected that's what's called
serendipity yeah and so I began to study
that and that led me eventually to
propose in about 1982 that THC would be
useful marijuana would be useful for the
treatment of Tourette's syndrome ok the
reason these are related is because
Tourette's syndrome is a motor disorder
you have people that have normal
intellect absolutely normal in a
intellect they're just perfectly alright
except they have these involuntary
movements and they shout obscenities and
they have no control over it and I could
propose that if you had a drug that
would slow down motor movement in other
words in the rats it really slowed them
down to where they actually stopped but
it would have a therapeutic effect in a
disorder where there's too much movement
right and I went to Australia and gave a
paper on that down in Australia and it
hit the Australian press and there was a
guy in Australia who had Tourette's
syndrome he was a young man about 30
years old and he had been retired by the
Australian government and given a
pension because he couldn't work and
Tourette's syndrome is very
uncomfortable because people because
people avoid you you can't interact you
know it's it's a brutal kind of a
disorder right and this guy went out in
the back the back country out in the
bush and he read that in the paper he
smoked a pipe of marijuana and his tics
went away and he went back into society
and went back to work
so anyway there
the point of this almost endless story
please forgive me is that there are
beneficial effects that come from
unexpected places natural products that
are a source of real medicine right it
has has marijuana now been approved for
Tourette's or is there is there a
recommended way to take it now for
Tourette's does that mature into muscle
it's not approved I I don't believe it's
approved there was a product a
cannabinoid product that was approved I
can't remember the name of it and it's
not widely used now but marijuana could
be used for Tourette's either taking it
orally which is probably the best way to
take it the downside of that is it takes
a little bit more with a edible
marijuana but the advantage is that it
lasts longer another case of this
marijuana and Tourette's was a kid in
Arizona who had Tourette syndrome and it
was refractory to every treatment and he
was having trouble but he was a
sophomore in high school and he went he
went out one Christmas holiday with his
friends and after he and his friends
went out his Tourette syndrome symptoms
went away and it turns out it was
because he was smoked marijuana and he
actually found that he could smoke
marijuana on Sunday night and be okay
till Thursday smoke on Thursday and he'd
be fine until Sunday and he smoked twice
a week and he went graduated from high
school went on to college and last time
I heard from him he had graduated from
college and he was married and getting
along just fine but you can eat it you
can smoke it it's not approved primarily
because in the United States it's still
illegal right right now no your what
you've told us here
our different stories of individuals
taking taking marijuana and at helping
with their Tourette's and that's very
similar to like the stories that you'll
find in the Black Plague where people
are you know they're taking their urine
there's there's a guy who drinks three
handfuls of urine a day and it it allows
him to not get the Black Plague so how
do you how do you take how do you go
from these individual stories which
might be coincidental or might there
might be an actual effect there how do
you go from there to actually
demonstrating that this particular
molecule works or this particular drug
works for this particular disease and
then getting approval for it through the
FDA I am so happy that you asked that
because I often say that the plural of
anecdote is not beta and you know the
Internet and the literature is replete
with before and after photographs
testimonials yeah and you should always
be suspicious of that very much so
because of these anecdotes and they were
published in in journals I was telling
you about Hemmings and yellow leaves
published the article about the
Australian guy that went out into the
bush and doctors actually examined him
and documented it against his medical
history but because of those stories
there was a group in Germany then that
ran some experiments on Tourette
syndrome and they did not find a big
effect not too big it seems that the
cannabinoids affect motor behavior more
than the mental behavior of having
compulsions and shouting obscenities and
that kind of thing it was not a big
effect and you should always say is it a
big effect I get I get so annoyed when
people don't run the experiments that
you're talking about John yeah when I
talk about an experiment
I'm talking about you get a group of
people that are pretty much a
homogeneous group of patients that have
the disorder and you randomly divide
them into two or more groups and in a
blind fashion and by that I mean nobody
knows who gets the drug and who does not
get the drug they're not even the people
who are running the experiment it's done
by a third party you get coded vials you
can't tell what's in there and then you
analyze the data and the effect has to
be big yeah it has to be big enough that
it's a convincing effect because when we
take medicine as a patient if I went out
today to take medicine as a patient I
would expect it to work in me in other
words I expect it to work on an N of one
and I expect it to work in most of the
people that have a group of ten let's
say we'd expect we have a good
expectation that it'll work I got so
annoyed when I read experiments where
they have 3,000 patients in a clinical
trial for example in Alzheimer's disease
another area in which I work Biogen this
last spring had a new drug for
Alzheimer's disease and the results were
so dismal at a mid point that they said
that they were going to pull it and they
were not going to seek FDA approval and
then somebody went back and looked at
the data and you may recall this scandal
and then they said oh no it works we're
gonna go to the FDA we're gonna work it
out well it might be statistically
significant if you have 10,000 people in
a trial 3,000 people on a trial you know
maybe it works a little bit right and
maybe it's enough to be statistical but
that does not mean it's clinical and
it'll work in some people and not others
and so if you're lucky
to evaluate a substance you see some
claim on the internet and you get all
these testimonials and they may actually
have run an experiment look carefully at
this experiment was it impatience did it
make a big difference is it something
that's likely to help people yeah
and so the the reason that I first got a
hold of you well recently got a holding
you for those just just so everybody
knows our history together I met I met
Don Moss probably was it five years ago
or so oh I think it was more than that I
wasn't it was 2010 when I was working
with Jim summer 10 we were yeah so so
you were you were working on this
Alzheimer's treatment that needed
funding from investors so can go into
clinical trials right and so I helped
you guys do some marketing for that do I
did an animation for you guys and back
then I you know you and I had lots of
conversations about about you know kind
of the alternative medicine and how
things go from you know kind of fairy
tale drug treatments and and alternative
medicine into real medicine and one of
the things that you told me I don't know
if you remember the quote but it was if
a drug doesn't have a side effect it
doesn't have a real effect and that that
stuck with me for a long time and you'd
also mention that you were studying
marijuana for for Tourette's and just
recently here in Canada there was a
paper published saying that marijuana
might be useful in the treatment of
Kovan 19 and my my wife she's a nurse
and her fellow nurses were super excited
about this and like oh people people can
treat can treat kovat with with
marijuana and a bunch of people are just
they just started smoking weed
to treat to protect themselves against
coven and I sent you the paper and I'm
like does this look legitimate to you do
this like a serious thing that people
should
be considering and you know your
response was well no and especially not
just to smoke it because if you look at
the if you look at the research they had
a very specific strain of marijuana it
was not high in THC it was high in was
the other what's the other one in THC
that's labid I'll yeah it's CBB Yabba
dial and the their trial was very very
preliminary and it was it was taking it
orally and there's actually there's
actually problems if smoking of course
causes a mild inflammation anytime you
smoke anything and there's actually been
problems here with the bladders that are
smoking a lot having symptoms that they
think or kovat symptoms because they're
having trouble breathing they're having
swelling in the and the respiratory
tract and so the heavy smoking is
actually causing problems for doctors
because it's clogging up the you know
that the testing facilities this isn't
happening so much anymore people aren't
so scared of kovat as they were
initially so people aren't getting these
false scares so much anymore but yet
this this excitement around marijuana
turned into an excitement around smoking
it which was not at all what the doctors
were even recommending and their
research was extremely preliminary and
so the it's kind of like everything that
people were told what they wanted to
hear
smoking marijuana cures you of this
disease and that's what they that's what
they heard but that's not what it was
actually stated at all and it's just
amazing how this information gets out
into the public and as people are
sharing it person-to-person as the media
reports on it
things just balloon out of control and
you get these really weird and
appropriate explanations of how to treat
this new disease you know this kovat 19
and it's it's really spectacular to
watch this happen and it was just I was
I was glad we'll send that to you and
you pretty much get your immediate
responses no this is not this is not
what people are saying it is
so I'm glad you sent it along and in
defense of the authors that wrote this
paper and I have navigate with me today
yeah
in defense of the authors they don't
make that claim right at all and it is a
scientifically done paper and it's done
in cell culture and they do get some
tiny effects I don't know if you can
tell the difference between the height
of the bars in there yeah yeah but
that's that's not a very big effect and
it's in cell culture and what's
interesting to me when you read the
paper that it worked in oral tissue one
cannabinoid worked in oral tissue
another one worked in lung tissue and a
different one work you know and in nasal
tissue and that kind of thing so if you
were gonna smoke marijuana
to block they were trying to block the
receptor the ACE to receptor which is
the door at the door way by which kovat
enters the cell yeah if you were going
to smoke marijuana to block that which
cannabinoid which strain of marijuana
would you smoke and secondly the effect
here is so small and it's in cell
culture that any idea that this is a
basis for using it in humans to avoid
covetous is unfounded
you know it's an example of maybe
pseudoscience no this is good science
but it's misinterpreted in the Internet
into thinking that it could actually be
used you know you might as well put
mercury in a thing around your neck for
cover as far as that goes right so so
what you're saying is that they did good
research and they recommend in there
that they don't recommend using it that
what they say is that this should be
looked into they say we're saying that
it has this effect in cell culture and
we think that people should look into
this more research should be done on
this and yes and because it's because
it's marijuana and people like to smoke
my
the media just took it over and just
blew it out of proportion and that's got
to be really frustrating for I mean
because you've actually studied medical
marijuana I'm sure you're aware of the
the the huge biases you have on the pro
marijuana and the anti marijuana groups
where it just it becomes super hard to
do your job right
well because very political right for no
reason really right
I often like to say that if marijuana if
THC had been discovered in a laboratory
with somebody working on a problem and
and THC does have some very good medical
uses for example it's wonderful to treat
nausea vomiting and stuff it's not the
best drug for that but it's very
effective at it like I said it's good
for Tourette's syndrome it's good for
other things as well
it's a good for epilepsy some of the
cannabinoids are well-established but if
it had been discovered in a laboratory
for one of those uses it would have been
an approved pharmaceutical yeah but it
was discovered on the street and
therefore you have a drug that's
effective and the side effect is
desirable well if the side effect of
marijuana was that you were miserable
then it would have been approved yeah
yeah and that I I think I believe that
that's changing with marijuana now I
mean here in Canada it's now legal for
recreational use and medical use in
Oregon it's legal now for you know I'm
from Morgan it's now legal there for
medical and recreational so it looks
like that might change in the future do
you have any idea as to as to when that
might change at a national level so that
we can really start using using this as
an actual medicinal drug well I would
like to say that in the United States
and I'm in Colorado now in Colorado was
one of the first states to begin to
legalize recreational use of marijuana
and fortunately the medical use of
marijuana has been approved by states in
various states like Oregon very
forward-looking also but at the national
level and the national level controls
the FDA of course at the national level
I don't know that there's any real
movement to legalize the use of
marijuana especially recreationally but
they might eventually get something in
medicinal uses but right now it's a
Schedule one drug i believe it used to
be a Schedule one drug which means that
it had no medical use whatever and that
it was it was in the highest category of
risk for people and and of course it's a
good example we know very well that the
risk of using marijuana is relatively
low it's it's lower than drinking
alcohol it's lower than most group drugs
actually right and that it really is
it's it's kind of a tragic story with
the big it got associated with when was
it first illegalized what do you know
when it was put on Schedule one well no
I don't but it was in the 1930s and
1940s that there was a lot of scare
about marijuana and then there was a
drug act that resulted from not just
from marijuana but from a lot of things
that came along in the nineteen thirties
or forties yeah
and that that was um yeah I remember
having read that that back in the 30s
people thought it would make you
dangerous it would make you violent and
then and then of course it was
associated with the hippie movement in
60s and so it's it just had it had all
these weird stigmas attached to it which
is has made it really problematic for
for doing research on it and and and so
on right now we've got this kovat crisis
and there's just
every everything you can imagine that
people are saying you can use to treat
kovat we had for the first time in my
life and I don't know if this is first
time in your life - but we had
politicized treatment so
hydroxychloroquine was being used by
Republicans and being rejected by
Democrats as a treatment you have you
know Democrats wear masks Republicans
don't there's a it's the weirdest I've
never seen anything like this have you
ever seen anything like this no but I
think it's a symptom of our time I have
never seen our nation so divided and so
politicized before in my life to where
it actually goes down into medical
treatments of a disease that is it
absolutely amazing to me it is I do see
that in you know reading about the Black
Plague I do see that that was happening
different governments would give
different recommendations where like
about food that you should be eating
whether or not you do quarantines or
other different things whether or not
you pray or there was I think it was
Italy the their their official medical
recommendation was to spend time every
day looking at gold and silver for the
pleasure that it gives you and it will
help you stop from getting the disease
there they're things were very political
back then and I think maybe maybe this
is a symptom of a new disease that no
one knows how to treat and as having a
huge effect on the culture or maybe
maybe it's a symptom of just the left
and right are so dramatically different
now than they have been in the past but
it's it's really something amazing to
see I'm I'd like to talk with you now
about your your work with Alzheimer's
but maybe before we maybe before we dig
into that just talking about the FDA in
general so again kind of going back to
this Tim mentioned quote what do you
call alternative medicine that's been
proved to work you call it medicine
and in America what that usually means
is that a drug has been approved by the
FDA a drug war treatment has been
approved by the FDA and is now being
used in hospitals and being given out by
doctors and what are your general
thoughts on the FDA have is the FDA
really helping us avoid snake oil and
other you know just lame medical
treatments and what do you see as the
pros and cons of this this FDA culture
that we have in the United States well
yes the FDA is protecting us against
snake oil treatments and if the FDA
we're not keeping the Gate on those
there are just hundreds or thousands of
people that have snake oil treatments
that have no basis in fact right happy
to go out and sell you all kinds of
bogus stuff and in fact you can see it
in the sunday paper and insert in the
sunday paper today yeah they'll sell
supplements and they'll make outrageous
claims and they'll have a two-page ad
and before-and-after pictures and it's
all very convincing until you realize
that there's only one person or a group
of people that are pushing this one item
nobody else is and I would like to say
that if you hit on something that works
and you can demonstrate it the first
thing that happens is a lot of other
people generally will get on the
bandwagon and if you have something they
will push it forward they will find an
alternative structure of the same thing
and they'll make it medicine and they'll
make money but the FDA does a good job
of protecting us against a lot of things
although you should read every claim
that you see and see whether it says
this was not approved by the FDA for the
treatment diagnosis or anything else of
a disease that means it's not FDA
approved even though they claim it's a
supplement and they have all kinds of
data
the problem with the FDA is that it has
fossilized drug the drug approval
mechanism in the United States to the
point that it's enormous ly expensive
I'll take five hundred million dollars
to get a drug for Alzheimer's approved
at a minimum a nine hundred five hundred
million is that a normal is that a
normal cost for any drug to get approved
by the FDA
I think Alzheimer's is a little higher
than most other drugs because proving
efficacy in Alzheimer's disease is more
difficult okay you know if you have a
treatment for some short-term illness
you can tell in a matter of a few months
or a few years whether or not it's going
to work or not and it's real easy to
prove if it's for a broken leg you can
tell whether the light heals very
quickly and take an x-ray with
Alzheimer's it's a very slow process and
yet to follow the clinical trials have
to go for years and you know you're
studying memory and memory might get
better and might get worse and having
run an Alzheimer's disease clinical
tutoring clinical trials I can tell you
that it's very difficult because of the
variability in memory yeah even a
demanded alzheimer's person will have a
good day when they can remember
something a bad day when they can't and
so if you measure them on one day it
looks like the drug work and another day
and you know it's it's very difficult so
and it's hard to tell with Alzheimer's
because in the old days anyway they're
getting better at it now but you
couldn't even tell who is for sure an
Alzheimer's patient until they went to
autopsy now they you know we have a
better way of doing it but when you
can't tell whether your patient has the
disease or not you have people who don't
have Alzheimer's disease in the
Alzheimer's group which means you've
mixed in control patients in the
Alzheimer's group and in the control
group that you didn't think I had
Alzheimer's they do and so yes it's
almost impossible so anyway that makes
the trials really expensive
just to be really clear here getting FDA
approval isn't expensive because you
have to pay off some shady government
official it's expensive because doing
the research is expensive right that's
that's right but you know it also
probably pays to pay off the officials
that's not that's not what makes it run
into the 500 million and also it takes
years to run these things remember in
the United States and in most countries
of the world the patent that you get for
your drug is only good for 17 years from
the day that you file it 17 years I
guess a very recent study five or six
years ago of drugs that were approved
somebody went back and studied what was
the amount of time between when you got
the patent and when the drug was
approved by the FDA now remember it's
only for those drugs that got approval
and I'd like to come back and talk about
a lot of drugs that don't get approved
and why they don't get approved but it
took thirteen point nine years on
average from the day you got a patent
until it was approved oh wow well let's
just round it up and say 14 years that
only gives you three years after you get
approval to recover the five hundred
million dollars you've spent along the
way right so the FDA it makes it very
expensive and makes it very long so but
let me well let me just ask one more
question here on the on the the the
patent stuff here so when your patent
runs out all you can see obviously you
can still keep selling your drug and
making money but once the patent runs
out is it you have to publish the
formula for the the drug so that other
manufacturers can make it - is that how
that works
well when you file for the patent and
your patent is issued the drug and at
all of the details about it become
public information so anybody can do it
from the date of your patent but but
they
but legally they can't sell it that's
right right when the when the patent
expires then a generic drug company can
go to the FDA and they can make a very
simple inexpensive application and they
can use the data that were supplied by
the original company and they say look
all of these data show that it's safe
and effective and they put in this
abbreviated application and it's
approved before the patent expires the
FDA will not allow them to refer to the
other company's data right so to get it
approved they would have to run their
own clinical trial and they cannot sell
it because the patent will bar selling
it for that use they cannot sell it for
the approved use until the patent
expires right so so if you have a really
complicated molecule that not many
people can make you might not have to
worry so much about the patent running
out because you're still gonna be the
only one making that drug for years to
come so you can you can earn back that
five hundred million dollars but if you
have a really simple molecule that's
that a lot of companies are already
making for whatever reason and you just
found that it works to treat a disease
if you if you have you have to be really
careful because as soon as that patent
runs out someone else is gonna make it
way cheaper than you and you will no
longer make any money you might not make
any money after that so the foreign
investor if if this drug costs 500
million dollars and you want to invest
in it there's almost no incentive if the
molecule is simple to invest in it
because even if it works it doesn't
matter you're not gonna be able to make
a return on that investment so that's
that's the big problem
that the FDA causes for people who are
even even who have discovered a drug
that works sometimes it is not
profitable to go through the process of
getting it approved that's right there
are a lot of drugs that fall off of what
they call the patent cliff and they may
be wonderful drugs that really work
and the FDA holds them up
so long and makes it so expensive that
the manufacturer realizes that they're
only going to have two years left when
the patent expires and they'll drop a
perfectly good drug there are excellent
drugs that are sitting on the shelf and
they're not used because of patents and
because this is common knowledge now
there's also tons of snake oil salesmen
that say that their drug is one of those
or their molecule is one of those and
they use that as an excuse so you've got
you've got the truth of this this is a
real thing that really happens you have
good drugs that are not approved by the
FDA because of money and then you have
these salesmen that are lying to
patients saying that their particular
molecule is one of those so there's just
mass confusion for consumers like how
are we supposed to wade through this
theoretically if a drug is a drug right
and falls into the category of a drug if
it's not approved by the FDA you can't
sell it yeah where what happens is they
say well this is a supplement right or
this is a nutritional supplement and
that's where the confusion comes in
supplements are not regulated and people
can sell those as treatments etc when
they don't when they don't work well
okay I know you had something else you
wanted to get to but just how does that
work like let's say that let's say that
I have a drug that's I want to go on
trial and it's gonna be too expensive to
go through trial can I just call it a
supplement then even if it's like some
molecule that I'm manufacturing it in a
in a lab theoretically according to the
law no you can't just call it a
supplement the FDA has definitions of
what is a drug and if it falls into that
category then you cannot just call it a
supplement I have a drug that's in limbo
it was patented that patent has expired
it really works it's wonderful but I
can't go out and sell it and call it a
supplement because
it's chemical and it's not like anything
that's natural it doesn't supplement any
you know normal kind of process that you
would think of as a supplement there's a
drive it says so to call something a
supplement it has to be like from an
actual like food item or plant or
animals is that right well yes I think
so
I think so well that's it's a really
complicated legal definition okay anyway
a drug does not count as a supplement
generally if you went out and sold it as
a supplement for example lesson I could
go out and sell lesson as a supplement
and lesson might be a really reasonable
supplement it's phosphatidylcholine and
it facilitates the production of
acetylcholine in the brain that's its
mechanism of action I could go out and
sell it as a supplement it wouldn't have
to be approved as a drug but also we
know that lesson even though it has a
wonderful mechanism of action that's
well understood it doesn't work but and
so it would never show efficacy that the
FDA would want okay you can take all the
lettuce and you want to and in fact it's
a food additive you'd have to take a lot
more of it but let the Sun would be sold
as a supplement and the reason it
doesn't work is it gets metabolized into
triethylamine x' in the blood it makes
you smell a little bit like fish and it
never makes it where it's supposed to go
okay but that would be a supplement
let's say it it didn't it didn't get
inactivated let's see basically you're
saying it gets deactivated by the
stomach yes in the blood actually in the
but let's take st. John's wort there's
another example of an herb that is
natural and it does have scientifically
substantiated
clinical trials that shows that it
raises the mood it works as an
antidepressant and it's it's fairly
effective you could sell st. John's wort
perhaps as a supplement and it might not
need to be approved as a drug if you
were going to refine it and you're gonna
manufacture the active ingredient in st.
John's wort it escapes me at the moment
I don't remember what it is yeah and you
were gonna sell it under XYZ
pharmaceuticals you'd probably have to
get approval okay so so it it's sounding
like the legal definition which you say
is complex it has something to do with
how how processed a thing is once you
get into the very specific molecules it
becomes a drug instead of a a herbal
treatment or or a supplement and so okay
that's really interesting I had I
mentioned this to you before the show my
ear doctor growing up he ended up
quitting his job I think he had to quit
his job because he got in a car wreck
and the pain that he was experiencing
was so intense that he ended up having
to quit his job and recently he got into
a multi-level marketing scam selling
this molecule or selling the supplement
that cures everything and he got ahold
of me because I make these science
videos you should make a video about
this this supplement it's now it's
changing the world it's gonna
it'll make you live 10 years longer and
reduces pain does all this stuff and he
showed me the papers that were that
backed up his claims and what happened
is it was a it was a trial of this
supplement on a cell culture and it
increased the cells metabolism I made
that made the cells metabolize their
metabolism speed up and I looked at what
the supplement was and I had a bunch of
caffeine in it it was like different
different different herbs that have
caffeine in them and so I wrote him back
I said okay this is not this is not
showing that it cures anything it
increases the metabolism in cells and of
course it
it has caffeine in it and he wrote me
back extremely angry he said I'm a
doctor you don't know what you're
talking about and it was just a crazy
experience and he no longer talks to me
anyway I've known him since I was a kid
he was like friends of our family and
everything so it's like this these
problems are very deep in our culture
and and these marketing schemes are
really increasing this and this
confusion between a supplement and a
drug so I just I think that was a little
bit of a tangent but I just I just I
just want to point out how serious this
problem is in our society here well I'm
glad you brought that up because that's
a good example you asked me how can
people tell the difference between snake
oil and real medicine right and
generally the line is pretty clear
medicines are approved and manufactured
and sold and they have gone through the
process where they have been shown to be
effective mm-hmm and the FDA is pretty
rigorous about if effectiveness even
though I complained earlier about them
approving drugs that have little effects
but they have an effect
maybe not clinically valuable like we
want it to be but they have an effect
and they're safe but when you get a
supplement or something that is being
promoted by one person right and nobody
else is jumping in to run clinical
trials on it even people who oppose the
idea are going to jump in and start
running experiments and there should be
a whole body of literature that show
that there should be clinical trials
there should be people who take it right
and it should not just be testimonials
oh it worked it didn't work like I said
earlier the plural of an anecdote is not
data yeah and you can tell pretty easily
and and slick presentations hype
and appeal to Authority like all this
guy is a medicine on the Medical Faculty
of XYZ faculty in New York or whatever
and you know that's just not convincing
yeah yeah I know multi-level marketing
companies are really good at doing this
though they they will pay one doctor you
know hundreds of thousands of dollars to
come and do a presentation about the
efficacy of their herbal treatment for
whatever and then they had these big
conventions all their marketers come in
there it's a big party there's you get
all excited it's almost like a religion
I actually my first job as when I
actually started my career in graphic
design and marketing and my first actual
professional job I worked for a
multi-level marketing company that
taught people how to trade in the stock
market and I saw it I didn't really know
what MLMs were all about when I first
started there but I looking at I was in
the I was in the background behind all
this and seeing what goes on and it was
insane like we we had we had this this
stock market guru guy who had been sort
of successful as a stock trader
everything was exaggerated his success
and he was used as as the expert it was
just it was just amazing it was it was
so dishonest and the the way that
multi-level marketing works is you don't
have to have a real product that
actually works
people are making money basically in
most cases it's a pyramid scheme where
you're just you're making money off
getting more people to come sell your
product with you and you make money off
their sales but you're not actually you
don't have to have a product that works
because people are excited about the
get-rich-quick scheme and so you can
market completely bogus stuff through
these and like you said if something
works people are gonna jump on it you
know you don't unless it I think there
might be some products that sell best in
a multi-level marketing scheme like
maybe something that's really
complicated to use you'll have people
that your friends teach you how to use
it or there's like some people that
people things that people are
embarrassed to buy it
door you know there's there's a lot of
like sex toys for women are sold through
MLM and that's probably like the most
comfortable way for some women to buy
these these products they actually want
is their friend to come to their house
and show them how they work and so on
but the for the most part these
multi-level marketing things it's it's
to sell garbage as a get-rich-quick
scheme and they are just dominating
might like my facebook I all my friends
from high school or let me tell you
about this new product I have and it's
it's so obnoxious I it's a yeah well my
my experience with multi-level marketing
was when I was an undergraduate and my
wife and I were broke living in a
trailer when I was an undergraduate I
sold Amway products now my products you
know you can clean your bathroom with
them and stuff they actually work but
the way he made money was to get other
people hooked on have parties at your
house and sell them and and keep the
hype up yes multi-level marketing works
in drugs too and the drug companies pay
big names and they become what they call
thought leaders and they go to
conferences and you're supposed to bow
and and you know wave and clap and then
celebrate the break the breakthrough
another thing if somebody says it's a
breakthrough that the drug is a
breakthrough yeah you know it's a red
flag okay most improvements are
incremental right and one drug will be
much better than the other sometimes
they'll be a real change in the in the
marketing I mean a drug will be
substantially better than any others but
it's not going to be some guy on the
internet telling you about it right it's
going to be published in journals and
there'll be clinical trials it'll it'll
be obvious right right I
well let's I guess let's dive into the
molecule you've been studying for
Alzheimer's
which is not a treatment it is not a
cure for Alzheimer's it doesn't even
slow its physical progression but it
enables people to live longer with
functioning brains when they have
Alzheimer's let's talk about that that a
little bit here well first of all I want
to give an update John yeah ten years
ago the thinking was that these
molecules would not slow down the
progression of the disease okay and in
the last three to five years there have
been data that indicate these molecules
do in fact slow down the progression of
the disease but let me back up for a
moment my drug isn't a cholinesterase
inhibitor and one of the problems that
I've had in developing this drug is the
cholinesterase inhibitors were the ones
that were first introduced in the middle
1990s as tatran and Denis pizzelle and
realistic mean and they were introduced
for the treatment of dementia and
dementia
results from the absence of sufficient
acetylcholine in the brain you don't
have enough acetylcholine in the brain
you can't remember anything it's like
with Parkinson's disease you don't have
enough dopamine in the brain then you
don't get control of movement and so
they thought well we'll enhance a single
column they introduced cholinesterase
inhibitors so let me just explain
technically what this is doing so you've
got you have a cetyl choline which is a
molecule that your brand needs to send
messages between nerves and then you
have acetylcholine esterase which is a
protein that eats acetylcholine so that
that acetylcholine doesn't stay in the
brain triggering nerves after they're
supposed to stop being triggered and so
if you have an acetylcholine esterase
inhibitor so if you have an
acetylcholine eater'
inhibitor that means that less
acetylcholine gets to stay in the brain
longer and so if you have a disease like
Alzheimer's where you don't have enough
acetylcholine the acetylcholine esterase
inhibitor helps you helps raise your
seat
kollene numbers essentially right and
and we should refer your viewers to the
video the inmate explaining how these
work I'll link to that in the video
description there okay but anyway so the
cholinesterase inhibitors got sort of a
bad name because theoretically they
would work and in clinical trials they
will work a little bit here we here
again we get to the small effect problem
they didn't make dramatic differences
that they were expected to and the
reason for that is because acetylcholine
also runs the intestines and the heart
and other organs in the body and so when
you take a cholinesterase inhibitor to
work in the brain the first thing you
know you have over stimulation of the
intestines and stomach and you get
nausea vomiting and diarrhea so the
question is how badly do you want to try
to remember something yeah when you do
remember it's mainly nausea vomiting and
diarrhea honey what they were my drag
avoids the nausea vomiting and diarrhea
for reasons that are technical but
anyway my problem is that the
cholinesterase inhibitors have an a have
a bad name because they're ineffective
right and the thing that changed
dramatically in 2015 2016 and 2017 is
that a group in france and i see i'm
time as somebody else's research not my
own so that's that will tell you that
it's likely to be more valid than if i
were telling you about my owners but
some people in france in paris did an
experiment this is a real experiment
where they took a whole group of
Alzheimer's patients and they randomly
divided the group into two groups one
group got a cholinesterase inhibitor
called the nip is ill and the other
group got a placebo and nobody knew is
double-blind which means you know that
they weren't blind but the doctors
the doctors don't know who's getting the
real drug and the patients don't know
who's getting the real drug that's right
it was double-blind placebo-controlled
and they gave one group to nip pizzelle
for a year and the other group got
placebo for a year and at the end of the
year then they evaluated the patients
and who was astounding about this study
is that Donna pizzelle treated patients
actually showed a slowing of the atrophy
of the cortex Alzheimer's patients it
didn't stop it but the big problem in
Alzheimer's disease is that your brain
is basically deteriorating and you can
see it physically in the MRI and that's
what they were measuring it's not you
know all they said it was better and I
was bunch of hand waving you know all
these patients were all good but they
could actually showed on the MRI and
they did the experiment again with an
another group of patients and they
showed that it slowed the atrophy of the
hippocampus and the hippocampus is an
area of the brain that's critical to
memory absolutely critical right if
anything happens to the hippocampus you
can't remember anything yeah some some
people who know the history of
psychology you may remember the famous
patient HM and HM had some surgery on
his hippocampus for epilepsy and after
he had surgery on his hippocampus
couldn't remember anything I'm pretty
sure he lives in Montreal I I think he
might might have but anyway the
hippocampus is one of those key areas
and campus after fee was slowed and then
also the basal forebrain an area another
area critical to Alzheimer's disease
showed a slowing of at repeat atrophy
the reason that I'm so excited about
this is that in 2014 and that's just
when it was published and nothing has
changed since 2014 with regard to draw
related amyloid but in 2014 there was a
review of all of the clinical trials on
Alzheimer's disease for drugs to block
amyloid and in 2014 there were 400
clinical trials on drugs intended to
block amyloid and zero yeah well those
trials showed any benefit for slowing
the progression of Alzheimer's disease
and now I was laughing about Biogen
earlier and their amyloid drug this year
they still have it in a clinical trial
well you know science is a database
endeavor and when you have 400 trials
that say that something is not working
you know there might be a message here
right you also have this class of drugs
that's been poo-pooed as a fairly
ineffective symptomatic treatment and in
fact the drugs that we have are fairly
ineffective and symptomatic but they're
better than the ones for amyloid yeah
and so we're really hopeful that someone
will take off on they call an ester ACE
inhibitors now and start really studying
them as a way to stop Alzheimer's and so
they have so what you're saying is that
that this trial in France there was an
acetylcholinesterase inhibitor trial
that was not the same molecule that
you're looking at it was it was it it
was the one that's currently being used
right yes yes it's not my molecule stamp
Iselle my molecule is several times more
effective than the denna pizzelle and
instead of slowing down the atrophy a
little bit I think by having an
effective molecule go in there that it
could be a fairly dramatic effect but
now see I'm saying this with some
skepticism I'm not willing to bump off
the end of the diving board here and say
it will we need to run that we need to
run the
yeah so so you found that your molecule
can what do we call the what do we call
these treatments that don't actually fix
the disease but are they stopgap
treatments right they're palliative
treatments is what it would call them
they'd be palliative there to treat the
symptoms yeah
and the cholinesterase inhibitors were
introduced just treating anthems way now
that looks like they're the only disease
modifying drugs yeah and and yours does
seem to treat the symptoms better than
the current molecules but you're not yet
sure because you haven't done the
experiments as to whether or not it
actually treats the underlying cause as
well that's right I've not done those
experiments although there was a guy say
Sara Berlanga in Florida ran an
experiment where he gave rats some
strokes and the purpose of the
experiment was to see whether stroke
damage could be benefited by a
cholinesterase inhibitor and in that
case he gave the rats some strokes and
then we gave them my molecules which is
MSF we gave it to them in very high
doses and it actually preserved some of
the cholinergic cells in the brain it
had this beneficial effect it did not
reduce the stroke volume the volume of
tissue that was damaged but it
selectively preserved the tissue that's
involved in memory and Alzheimer's
disease so we're real hopeful but we
have to run the experiments yeah yeah
because did just people know if
something works on rats it does not mean
it works on humans so absolutely but
it's better than cell culture yeah yeah
I've run their experiments in monkeys
also I run MSF experiments and mice rats
and monkeys and it looks very good in
those experiments and actually my
molecules been through three clinical
trials two of which are phase one trials
where you give the draw
to normal people to see if it's toxic
and then I got to give it to people in a
Phase two trial and it greatly improved
their memory and it had a lasting effect
on the improvement in their memory much
better than the existing drugs yes my
patent has expired and nobody's
interested in investigating it's one of
those on the shelf yeah yeah and dr.
Maas has a kind of a funny story to when
he was first first looking into this he
wanted to try it on his own dog and his
wife wouldn't let him so he try it on
himself instead she was okay with that
am I remembering the story right yes but
you've only told half of it the other
half is that after I'd done the
experiment on myself I took the drug for
several months and I drew my own blood
and had document what happened and
everything and it was very successful
and I never got sick I never got the
nausea vomiting or diarrhea is very
effective I went to a meeting and I
talked to one of my colleagues that
works on these drugs
a guy named Elkin gamsu and I was
telling you Elkin about this and Elkins
said oh yeah I said but you know when
you're developing your drug I think it
was Elkin gamsu don't quote me on it
anyway I think it was elegant he said
when you do toxicity studies don't do
them on dogs because dogs are really
sensitive to these kinds of drugs these
cholinesterase livers and so being a
scientist I thought well I want to know
yes
toxins and so I think that if dogs are
really sensitive to it that you should
do the experiment on dogs and so I
didn't have any money and for research
and I certainly didn't have a bunch of
dogs at my laboratory I just had rats so
I went home to my wife the same as I had
done the night that I explained her I
wanted to do an experiment on myself I
said you know I want to do an experiment
and I want to do it on dogs and I want
to use
beautiful Labrador Retriever named
Frankie Frankie was a lovely dog and was
totally compliant I could give her the
medicine I could take blood from her I
could do all the experiments on her I
did on myself and it would be a great
experiment and my wife said no it's okay
with me for you to do it on yourself but
not on the dog yeah I I would agree like
I I would rather I think I think I'd
almost rather do something on myself
then I'm one of my dogs I'm too attached
to my dogs well my wife her argument is
that I understood what I was doing to
myself yeah and the dog did not right
agreed to it
yeah it's almost it's almost like dogs
are so trusting it's almost too it's
almost too mean to try something on a
dog it just it's just yeah sorry I think
I think he got us off topic here so
we're talking about the the the approval
of this of this drug through the FDA yes
well it turns out that my problems the
only problem with my drug was the patent
right I did not understand patent law
and I screwed up the patent I did it
myself and we ran out of patent but my
drug could still be approved without a
patent under FDA regulations under
certain types of it they could have five
years of market approval or market
protection but I would like to talk if I
could John just a little bit about what
I would do if I ran the FDA okay yeah if
I ran the FDA a person would come
forward with a new drug yeah and they
would ask for approval and the first
thing that I would require is some
minimum evidence that it was not going
to harm the people on which it would be
tested in other words it wouldn't have
to
be okay with everybody in the whole
population elderly and other otherwise
sick people and everything but is there
is there any real probability of
significant harm if you tried it on a
human being if they brought forward
minimum safety data my interest would be
in does the drug work right and so I
would have what's called phase X it
would be the first one right now there's
a phase 1 phase 2 and phase 3 and phase
1 you'd prove that it's safe for
everybody in the world phase 2 you show
that it has efficacy it does what it's
supposed to and then phase 3 you
replicate on a grand scale what's
already one and two and the drug
companies cherry-pick the patients they
put in Phase three
etc and so it's not all that good okay
so so let me let me try and summarize
that so that the the way the FDA
currently works is you prove it you you
you think you've got a drug that might
be helpful for something so Alzheimer's
treatment in this case the first thing
you have to do is a fairly extensive
trial to show that it's not dangerous
then after that you can do a trial to
show that it works and you're saying
that if you were king of the FDA you
would reverse that so there's there's
minimal testing for safety first then
there's testing for efficacy then
there's extensive testing to make sure
that it's safe for the entire population
and then it would go out trial three
we're gonna modify what happens later
but yeah I would like to make clear to
our viewers that phase one or the first
time you introduce a drug into a human
is really a big step because up until
that time as john has pointed out you
know you've tested it in rats but rats
aren't humans you may have tested it
monkeys monkeys aren't human so the
first time you give it to humans you
better be ready for some unexpected
effects okay it's tested it thoroughly
in rats and dogs probably you're not
going to be surprised but it's still a
big
that yeah the first inhuman use is a big
step so if somebody came forward and
they tried it on 20 people or whatever
or they wanted to try it on 10 or 20
people and they had good animal data I
would say okay try it now the FDA would
normally say you have to try this on
normal people I would say try it
on the patient's we want to know if it
works so if it's an Alzheimer's drug
then give it to Alzheimer's patients now
I would pick patients that were an
otherwise good health I wouldn't pick
patients that had diabetes that had a
history of strokes they had multiple
sclerosis or heart disease we want to
know if it'll treat the Alzheimer's that
would be phase X and if it's showed a
benefit and phase X it would be in a
small group it would have to be a big
effect in other words what you would
expect to see in the clinic it are these
people going to get better if it's
successful there then I would run a
phase two study still in patients a
bigger study yeah one in patients to
replicate that it has to be replicated
maybe a few hundred patients yeah and
that could be in a few hundred patients
instead of a couple of thousand and it
could be over a year I think a drug
ought to make in effect in a year I mean
yeah in Alzheimer's patients you don't
have ten years to see if the drug is
going to make it better and then instead
of doing a phase three which is ninety
percent of the cost of a drug approval
is running phase three where you run it
in three or four thousand patients over
three or four years I would go into
conditional approval okay that is that
you would skip that and in fact put the
drug in a in clinics so that you are
treating regular patients that come in
and the drug would be very strictly
limited to only
indicated use there would be no
off-label use and there would be a
strict requirement that any untoward
effect any what they call adverse event
yeah had to be reported and let that be
phase three give conditional approval
for two years let it be tried in the
clinic a real clinic for two years work
now notice that I have cut out probably
three hundred million dollars in the
development of the drug and I've cut off
four or five years of drug development
time so that it can come to the market
and it can benefit patients early and at
a low cost now it seems like recently
there actually has been a bend toward
that direction at least for secondary so
like hydroxychloroquine we actually have
a question about that as to whether or
not you think it actually works and just
so people know the FDA just on the
fifteenth the FDA had had started
allowing the the testing very similar to
what you just said where patients could
come in and they they could actually get
it but they would have to be they had to
be told by the doctor that it's not
approved for Kovan nineteen this is a
drug that people are saying is is could
be used to treat Koba 19 but there's no
evidence that it can that it's actually
effective so doctors have been
administering it they tell the patients
there's no evidence that this is
actually this is actually working but if
the patient requests it they can get it
for them and then they have to report
any side effects and they have to
carefully follow the data as to whether
or not it's helping the patient and that
was being used in this sort of a trial
like what you're saying where it's
actually used in the real world
but just on the fifteenth the FDA's cut
that off they're saying that we're not
seeing any positive effects we don't we
don't think this is working so it's that
that trial is now done is that similar
to what you're saying what you think we
should be doing well yes in a way
hydroxychloroquine
got an emergency use authorization yeah
that is not drug approval right it's an
emergency youth use authorization and
the FDA can can allow people to use a
drug without going through the whole
approval process that I was talking
about all right and in this case it was
very reasonable because here we are in
the middle of a pandemic if a drug is
gonna work let's get it to people very
quickly and let's recognize that it's
for disease that has real lethal
consequences real severe health
consequences for which there's no
approved treatment and it could make a
big difference and the FDA will do that
on an emergency basis okay but you can't
get that for normal drug approval for
Alzheimer's or Parkinson's or anything
else cancer things like that so so
you're saying that you would like to see
the FDA open that up that option up to
more treatments even maybe look non
failed non fatal diseases yes yes and I
should also say that hydroxychloroquine
had also been used in humans so they
knew pretty well that it was safe pretty
safe it had been approved from for
malaria yeah so you know if we were to
open this up and by the way there's a
lot of people that are pushing for this
they're pushing for looser restrictions
on the FDA this isn't just you and you
know there's a lot of people pushing for
this if we were to do this I mean one of
the concerns I had the concern that I
have would be that patients would not be
able to tell the difference between a
thoroughly approved drug versus one of
these kind of like pre approved drugs so
excellent how would we communicate that
to people thank you I forgot to mention
that if I did this and I gave
conditional approval for the use of a
drug let's say FDA it would be in a
bottle that was clearly marked but not
approved it's only conditionally
approved
and the physician giving the drug and
the patient would have to be notified of
that and the patient would have the
choice do I want to live with my disease
the way it is
or do I want to take the risk of a drug
that has not gone all the way through
the approval rate and snow the only way
that you could use it is if the patient
knew that it had not been fully approved
that it had only been conditionally
approved and it would come in a bottle
marked that way and so you could not as
a snake oil salesman make a bottle like
that and say oh this is conditional
approval right you know I mean to get
conditional approval you'd have to show
that it worked
you know that there would be some
efficacy and that there's a good reason
to try it right then what would what
would the incentive be for a doctor
there because it sounds like the doctor
would have to do a lot of more a lot
more paperwork right documenting
everything much more carefully than than
normal and they might be prescribing
something that's not gonna be effective
or could actually hurt their patients
still and I know that you know I mean
doctors reputation is important they got
to maintain that so what would be the
incentive outside of an actual clinical
trial that's being funded why would a
doctor even want to do that well I would
hope that it would be a situation where
the patient was not receiving adequate
treatment with the approved drugs okay
and it would be an option that the
doctor could offer the patient as a
treatment and I think that doctor would
be motivated to help their patients at
least make him aware of it there would
be some doctors that probably would not
touch a conditionally approved drugs
right there probably would be and it
would probably be in medical schools
that they might be more inclined to do
it and in a private clinic somewhere and
I would hope that the paperwork could be
a simple checklist at the end of every
three months of a doctor's except
or anytime there's a severe adverse
event that they simply check it off and
mail it in to the FDA that day yeah and
the FDA could terminate it immediately
if there was a problem right yeah and
that that does that does sound very
reasonable I hate it we live in a really
bizarre
moment of history where we've got this
new disease that's affecting it's
destroying our economy it's affecting
all of us and at least indirectly and
yeah it's it's interesting to see our
world kind of go crazy about this and
I'm interesting to see where this goes
super super curious I is there anything
else we're at about an hour and a half
now is there anything that you want to
talk about specifically before we close
here on on any of your specific research
and then I just want to kind of give a
summary just basic simple advice for
someone who has a disease that's
untreatable what they should do when
they are looking at the world of
possible possibly promising new
treatments and possible snake oil that's
being thrown at them like what it is
they can do but before we do that is
there anything else you want to talk
about with your specific research on
this I want to say with Alzheimer's
disease that you'll read all kinds of
things where Alzheimer's disease is
associated with everything there's a new
breakthrough and even though Alzheimer's
disease might legitimately be associated
with certain lifestyle changes or
lifestyle factors Alzheimer's is a
organic disease in the brain and we
don't yet have a treatment yeah I would
like to say that as a result of those
trials in France that show that the nipa
cell slows the progression of
Alzheimer's disease and by the way these
were in very early stages of the disease
these were prodromal patients as a
result of that I'm
taking the netizen yeah but I am in a
demographic that is both really
sensitive to kovat I'm 75 yeah is my
risk from kovat is very great my risk of
Alzheimer's is great but I would only
take those things that really pass a
rigorous review yeah because otherwise
you're just wasting your money right all
right yeah that's a good a good summary
so take things that have been rigorously
reviewed only there there is insane
amount of incentive for people to sell
garbage that which is the the big
problem with alternative medicine with
with herbal treatments is that there's
so much incentive to sell something to
someone and it's so easy especially like
a mother with a sick child or you know
just a husband with a sick wife these
people are going to almost believe
anything because they're in this moment
of desperation and it's absolutely
horrible the types of things that end up
people getting taken advantage of and so
be very careful when you are in this
situation please recognize that you are
vulnerable and be very careful be very
guarded but it it just it is an
unfortunate fact of reality that we will
get diseases in our lifetimes that there
is no treatment there is no good
treatment and it's just uh you have to
be very careful you have to be very
vigilant to not be taken in by these
marketing scams and yeah follow the data
read read the papers how is someone
supposed to to analyze these scientific
papers so we talked about this this one
on marijuana earlier like how is the
public supposed to the media blow things
out of proportion so what is it what
does the person supposed to do when
they've reads about something in the
news that might be promising well first
of all look at where the information is
coming from
don't don't believe anything on the
Internet essentially right
it's really good information you may
find that it will be written about my
science writers real legitimate science
writers and they'll have a science
writer have an article in science
magazine or in some reputable magazine
some journal they won't be on the
Internet it won't be some guy that found
a study or whatever ya are with that
those people will review the literature
which sometimes is a little bit
impenetrable yeah but go to legitimate
sources go to PubMed which is the
National Institutes of Health Medical
Library and look it up and you can read
the abstracts and see if there's a
mechanism of action and if it's
legitimate and if there are experiments
that have been done and that will help a
lot but generally don't believe anything
in a slick magazine in a newspaper or on
the Internet
because it's just filled with so much BS
yeah well what what if it comes from a
popular politician which is the problem
we're seeing now I mean Donald Trump got
on TV saying that he takes
hydroxychloroquine which some people are
even doubting whether or not that's even
true but he he seemed to double down
when when evidence came out that it was
not useful he instead of changing his
mind he doubled down and I mean this is
this is insane to me like I've never
seen anything like this you've got a
politician very famous politician who
not only doubles down but says that he's
using it like what are we supposed to do
in this situation don't believe
Authority I think I mentioned earlier
the appeal to Authority somebody says
it's good oh this guy says it's good
he's an important guy or she is an
important person doctor whatever you
know
use your own mind yeah okay so but but
you say don't appeal to Authority but
then you're saying that there are
authoritative scientific magazines and
and this would come in there it's an
authoritative group so it's it's a whole
group of people that are testing each
other's ideas and that's where you
actually get more accuracy that's right
I'm saying don't appeal to an
authoritative personality right right
the scientific method is where people
can see the results for themselves yeah
and if I publish a paper that runs
contrary to somebody else's idea they
will run experiments to try to disprove
me and if I'm wrong it'll be exposed
immediately if I'm right they have to
agree with me right and it's through
that process that we will find people
who have run those studies and have
published them in peer-reviewed journals
that can speak with authority that is
they are data based their evidence based
conclusions it's not before-and-after
it's real experimental work it's real
data indicate that it works then you can
have confidence right right we've got a
couple of questions from viewers here
rouhani asks is herbal medicine
including homeopathy better than not
natural medicine so I guess you're
saying like mainstream medicine like and
well I would say no it's some some herbs
can be useful for sure but the the stuff
you get from a doctor has gone through
actual clinical trials and has been
approved by the FDA which is this this
process that we're talking about so
things that have been approved by the
FDA are have gone through this rigorous
research whereas as we mentioned earlier
these a lot of these herbal treatments
have not gone through any sort of
rigorous examination but they might in
the future end up going through that and
be
mainstream medicine yes I agree and in
fact a lot of these herbal medicines
will give valuable clues that lead to
the development of drugs but I also hear
people say well it's a natural product
and therefore it's safe and that's not
true yeah we know a lot of natural
products that are not safe they're very
toxic and the fact that whatever you're
dealing with might not be known to be
toxic does not mean it's safe in other
words the absence of data does not mean
it doesn't it doesn't have yeah these
doctors were drinking their own urine
back in the Black Plague days we now
know that's not the best thing to do
yeah but it's not toxic you know
probably sometimes it is it depends
yeah the the by the way the the World
Health Organization recommends that if
you drink your and you you need to
pasteurize it first okay because
actually drinking urine is used today by
many cultures as medicine so they they
say that they say that there's no
evidence that it works as medicine but
if you do use it pasteurize it first
which means that you need to eat it
that's a good idea although
theoretically urine from a healthy
person is sterile
yeah or basically aryl but you don't
know if it's a healthy person they're
not drinking urine is probably not a
good idea your body is getting rid of
all that stuff for a reason yeah they
were the big the big problem with it was
when MERS broke out that was coming
through camel urine so people were
actually getting a corona virus through
camel urine and camel urine in cultures
where there's a lot of desert travel
through camels there's there's if you're
stranded in the desert you're gonna
drink camel urine at some time in your
life and so that had become a
traditional use in certain cultures for
medicine and for showing how manly you
are you can drink camel urine and so
that was that was actually their big
concern you need you need to heat up
camel urine to at least 70 degrees
before drinking it to kill viruses yes
70 degrees Celsius in right before
drinking it because that
we'll kill coronaviruses so yeah that
was that was a big problem back in now
whenever MERS broke out so be careful
out there folks there's a lot of people
that are trying to trick you they're
gonna take advantage of you when you are
at your most desperate learn how to read
the literature talk to your doctor
be very careful yes thank you John for
the opportunity to talk about this I
really appreciate ya this is a lot of
fun and yeah thanks for coming on the
show Thanks so long for now everybody
stay curious